I don't know about you but I surely
enjoyed seeing the grim faces on some of
those other cable networks today after
president Trump's meetings with his NATO
counterparts in Brussels now it was
obvious that pundits and writers wrote
their scripts long before Air Force one
even touched down in Belgium of course
Trump was going to be an American
wrecking ball a bull in a china shop
further damaging in the North Atlantic
Alliance that had helped keep the peace
for 69 years Putin's poodle
yada-yada-yada
and then the president spoke bluntly
when he arrived that's no surprise and
plainly about a bizarre dynamic whereby
Germany the richest country in NATO is
enriching Russia the very country that
the Alliance wants protection from we're
supposed to against Russia
[Music]
now if you've listened to my radio show
with any regularity over the past six
years which you should have you would
have heard me speak both of the Nord
Stream one in the Nord Stream two energy
pipeline projects which are funded by
Russian business interests and make
Russia and maybe even Putin himself
billions of dollars in energy profits
now presumably that's enough money to
mean that Germany can finally pay all
the money into NATO dues that it
actually owes
well remember both Russia makes a lot of
money off of this and German interests
make a lot of money off these pipeline
projects too and as you can see there
the NATO chief responded to Trump's very
specific concerns with a flurry of
generalities punctuated by banality z'
it's not very convincing now Trump is
right if another country Russia controls
a big chunk of your energy supply well
you're giving up a huge amount of your
personal autonomy while at the same time
you're giving Russia the rope to hang
you with or maybe the light switch to
electrocute you with to keep the right
analogy going as the Washington Post's
rightly noted today Germany's energy
relationship with Russia has long
frustrated Washington and Eastern Europe
who fear that the Nord Stream 2 pipeline
which will bypass the Baltic nations and
Poland could be used to cut them off
from crucial energy supplies former
German Chancellor Gerhard schröder is a
top executive at the Russian government
controlled company that runs the
pipeline that's a cozy relationship now
wouldn't you like to see Schroder Swiss
bank accounts wouldn't you just like to
know how much he had to be paid to agree
to that
now what's clear after today is that
Donald Trump is not only not sucking up
to Putin he's trying to disrupt
Germany's cozy relationship with Russia
he's doing what friends often do with
friends who've gotten off track he's
having a frank and brutally honest
conversation with them in hopes of
writing their course and repairing the
relationship German Chancellor Angela
Merkel reacted to Trump's suggestion
that Germany is captive to Russia this
way the sleep evolved
directions for Nava don't want to get
bored well he pins their food as we
avoid in high height for instant
idleness conflict touched on on starts
via design or zachanassian sir I
understand [ __ ] politic muffin but I
understand you get it I don't feel good
well you're not gonna be independent for
long when Putin decides to shut down
that gas line did you hear an answer to
Trump's actual charges or questions
I didn't as the American president
Donald Trump is over in Europe looking
out for our interests and of course for
the independence of our allies which he
thinks it's really important and rightly
so the free rider days have come to an
end
Americans elected Trump in part because
they wanted to make sure that the
billions that we spend overseas are
billions very well spent
what a novel concept but you'd have
thought that Trump had worn a Russian
flag t-shirt to his NATO talks given the
hyperbole wafting from 30 rock today
Donald Trump is the most vivid
manifestation of the least attractive
characteristics in the national
character
we haven't been captured by Donald Trump
we have had our worst instincts affirmed
exacerbated and put in front of the
world he could not be doing Putin's
bidding more effectively if he were an
active agent of Vladimir Putin and the
KGB it's all coming to fruition and
there is a basic reason why Putin wants
to do it in President Donald Trump II as
an American president who goes at NATO
hammer and tongs and in a sense does
Putin's work for it what a ridiculous
comment asking our allies to pay their
fair share is going at NATO hammer and
tong he's actually trying to strengthen
NATO by saying we've got to keep this
alliance together by keeping our
military expenditures what we pledged to
do and and keep those at a level that
you know is fair for everyone two
percent but I got to tell
this was perhaps my favorite of all the
criticisms of Trump's NATO meetings
today what's the role of misogyny here
does Merkel remind him of Hillary the
does that help explain the Teresa May
issue he does not have a particularly
healthy relationship it seems with a lot
of strong women oh my gosh
Jon Meacham is like I really like Jon
Meacham a suspected biographer historian
but that was just stunning yeah yeah Jon
that's what it's all about it's not an
unseemly energy deal that in peril is
Eastern Europe or a country that's been
undermining its future safety while
asking us to pay for their protection
it's all about strong women oh my god
well here's an observation from one
muller has come up empty in his quixotic
quest to find trump collusion with
russia but perhaps he should turn his
investigation to germany where
politicians current and former are all
too happy to sell out their own people
for cheap Russian gas well I won't hold
my breath waiting for that probe to
start and in the meantime I'm glad we
have a president who is unafraid to
upset the applecart over in Europe and
call out truly dangerous international
collusion where it exists and he's
actually willing to do something about
it and that's the angle